about these disk tracks that rappers
make and [ __ ] it seems like if you make
a diss track like you're you're hurt
like you're upset and you're whining -
the older I get
you know if they're funny then that's
cool but if they're like yo I'm harder
than you and you suck hey man you're
rhyming Hey Dude are you a troll under a
bridge
you're just a [ __ ] grown man with a
job and you're like a hotel/motel
you're a grown man and you're like that
guy [ __ ] piss me the [ __ ] off you
know what record this shoes blues hey
dude
oh [ __ ] that guy made me so mad what he
said about me check this out
hit record thumbs bombs you're 30 ah I
don't know man it's just hilarious to me
that's how much we haven't come in upon
this man when you're on it so that's
what happened in hip hop this week like
I should [ __ ] talk about that but
that's what happened in hip hop week
that's where you come to me for all your
hip hop news babies